at the end
resilience is everything and if you're
believing in what you're doing uh and
you're keeping surrounding yourself with
with the right people
we'll nail it
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel an in media
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders and meet
guy barcelon co-founder and ceo of
simpleio guy is passionate about data
and the hidden gold inside of it he is
dealing with data for the past 18 years
business intelligence analytics and data
science and in the gaming space since
2010 before founding simple guy led
platika's data unit on its data
revolution time
gaia has a bachelor of science in
engineering of industrial management
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great and thank you for
inviting me to
talk to you thank you very very much for
being here you know that i i love
understanding how people evolve
throughout their career gain insights
into their different domains verticals
occupations and then go and start a
company based on those understandings uh
you have a really really interesting
journey from being from shanghai to
being a business analyst to being a bi
analyst director of business
intelligence with platika vp mobile data
at music lab and now a co-founder and
ceo at simple with a bunch of other
things in between that i that i skipped
around and but but it looks like a
really interesting journey from the
perspective of of just gathering all
these crazy experiences that lead you to
some interesting convictions in the
world of of decision making
and now you're bringing that into simple
so guy tell me a little bit about
yourself how you perceive your career
trajectory and then we'll dive into what
simple does and and how it's solving a
greater issue
cool so
you know i'm dealing with data
somewhere
since 2003 and i started my journey as a
business analyst uh for a company called
incredible
and back then when i when you i need to
to send like a management report a daily
report
you you went to your some kind of your
database and you copy paste some values
into excel sheet and then you run all
kind of excel and then copy the
information from the excel to an email
like a very long process
um
and i i found that i really love the
the the the data world but i don't
understand how it works
um so a few months later i joined the
company uh who dealt only with uh
building infrastructure for business
intelligence
and following the years i worked with
several companies in several industries
and and since i learned how to build the
entire process from
ground to
uh to the top it become more and more
interesting and i found myself that
there are very similarity between what
companies are facing in in all the
perspective related to data
uh and this is what serves me today i'm
always
trying to figure how what is the most
efficient
way to work with data because data is is
a cold mind and if you know how to work
with it properly it's a really important
factor in your ability to drive your
company to a better place and to be more
successful
what did you learn about handling data
as you were you know working as both a
business analyst but then a business
intelligence manager across a variety of
companies what what did you really learn
about about the the perhaps right and
wrong users of analyzing data
it's a very good question i i think one
of the the
the biggest thing that i found is big
data beside a fact type kind of a sexy
term
it it holds a lot of challenges and
sometimes leads companies to generate
store massive amount of data but at the
end when they need to take decision
based on this data that's where the
challenge because big data requires you
know the proper infrastructure and it
requires the proper analyst that knows
how to dig the important kpis out of it
and i think that what is more
appealing for most companies is working
with the right data not necessarily the
big data in today's world it's very easy
to create a very small application that
generates huge amount of data but the
the smart thing is how to to decide what
is important
at the beginning of the journey and then
at the end you can really work with
a very concrete kpis that help you make
them a better decision on a daily basis
right okay so tell me a little bit about
for me that's the question
what'd you say yeah go ahead
no no i'm go ahead that that's my that's
my that's i think that's my biggest
take-out from the daily world at this
point
before we started simple that then later
on the journey i found that uh
answering the what if and what could be
if we've just changed that a simple
factor three months ago we could do
better
that's something that came later for me
at the process and not my career
so take me a little bit later on then to
this idea of you know guesstimating and
and running simulations and being able
to make decisions
in advance for
a possible outcome that will come later
on
and today you're working you're with
simple
and you're helping people make these
decisions and run these simulations
especially for game developers but
otherwise it's very hard for them to do
what
what is sort of the big pain point that
you're tackling here
that you've
been inspired for simple
so
the idea for simple
was born in into the gaming space though
we do not consider ourselves as a gaming
company because at the end the
challenges that we're facing today i i
think can be found in almost every
company over on every online digital uh
business
uh
you always seek for optimization on a
very very simple
formulation
when you acquiring users for a specific
amount of money
you need to re return to generate a
positive return on investment
uh and the big challenge how you get to
this point
uh in the gaming space when you're
talking about millions of users with
that can be divided to tens of cohorts
and different classifications and
clusters and different profiles of users
uh each one of them is seeking for a
different uh experience and the thing is
that you know when companies are trying
to find this point the classic approach
you know it's running the whole concept
of a b testing uh
which used to be great and it still can
be great but it's expensive right you
must have these
capabilities in your application to run
a valid a b test which do not expose
users to two more than two uh
more than one variant and at the end
when you're looking at to analyze an a b
test results what's interesting is not
what happened after a day or a week you
want to see the long run you want to see
that the user that was exposed to the
successful variant
actually retained and came back and
continue paying
and this time cost a lot of money and
drive you as a company to spend a lot of
inefficient media
right at that point i thought to myself
if i could only build a small thing that
will help me to understand faster
and just to give a general perspective
what it could be if we just change this
parameter and then the other parameter
and what happened if we want to change
to
this is how this idea was born and i
think
and that
when it's when it's running it's
fascinating it's a groundbreaking
uh strategy to the way you're making
your decision and this is what is
fascinating me for the past for the past
years when we're when we start running
simple
so what i'm understanding from you is
while you know we've been able to do
traditional business intelligence
especially if we're looking at the
context of gaming
the ability to to actually use
to actually use some algorithms to
identify the game patterns and to then
through those patterns predict what is
going to be the customer experience and
then simulate on the different changes
that's really the aha moment that you're
bringing with you to to simple
yeah because if you think it's it's just
give you the general understanding what
happens beyond being behind the corner
if you just could have a general
understanding and yes it relies on a
very
efficient uh classification of user's
profile and identifying what is the root
and what is the cause what is the cause
and what is the effect
uh and once you're having uh this basing
on basic understanding
what
basically we're trying to do is just
pasting this a user's profiles with
different environment different reality
and and the power of a stimulation as a
service platform is that you're not
limited to
one linear a b testing or two linear a b
testing that one after another with a
two weeks iteration
we're running dozens or hundreds of
different uh what-if scenarios in terms
of you know minutes or hours and and for
us
that's the big promise uh of what we're
bringing to the world and i think it's
it's not about simple it's it's in a way
you drive your product team and your
monetization team to always seek for a
better
uh
performance not afraid to break anything
which is a very big concern in a live
and running game you don't you sometimes
you don't want to change anything even
even though you want to improve because
you're afraid to break something uh and
we want to break this friction give you
this endless sandbox to play as you want
get a general understanding of what's
going to be
and move forward
that makes it like smarter
yeah
so
from the analytics perspective
what do you what have you learned with
simple about you know games in general
if you're looking for example the gaming
market and the way games are built
and the strategic thinking around games
what are some non-trivial things that
you've observed
in the gaming world that perhaps a young
new game developer
may not even be aware of or may not even
know
to ask those questions as as they're
strategically thinking through their
game
okay it's a very interesting essay at
the end
the games do not work as like as a it's
not a one size fits all it's not like if
you'll take
some mechanics from one game
applying it to a different skin and
by magic it will work every game it has
its own soul
and
this soul is generated from from the
gener and from from the deepest uh core
game blue and the way that uh you know
that the interface surrounding it and
then the way that the the the player
experience the sound it's all part of
the same party and i think
one of the biggest stakeout that i have
so far in the in in this current journey
of most of my life and my my career
is first you always try to to innovate
it's not like you can do like a
just another slot game or just just
another coin master it doesn't work like
that the the the users are too smart
you know the millennials and then the
teenagers taking us such a
strong
cluster and
and portion of the active users and they
need innovation so you always
should look for them
what's new how you can tweak something
and then
build the entire uh
journey and experience around it and
that's for me the biggest tip that i can
provide for uh
for new game developers or for someone
who wants to
you know to step into this journey
uh despite the fact that
you have to work with veda
don't don't work with hunches
right now this idea of working with data
has it been is this a solved problem in
terms of
you know the acquiring the data and
knowing to
to take it from the customer actions and
the different experiences
so in other words are we at a point now
where the layer of data observability
and data collection has sort of been
solved in in in and now we're
transitioning that to be able to just
use the most effective tools to analyze
it or they're still gaps in in the world
of just collecting the data and knowing
which data to actually collect
no no i i think it's it's not a solved
problem i think and i see it almost with
every company that we're working with
it's the reliability of the data and and
the definition of what is really
important and what how
uh
the data pipeline looks like for me it's
something that hasn't been solved from
from the customer side and we can always
see cases when the data is not always
accurate sometimes it's missing
sometimes you have to you know create
all kind of
work around just to give that like the
basic
business picture to your customers and i
think it's better to have less data but
a reliable one something that you can
take a decision with it with
confident enough that what you're seeing
is is actually what happened in the
market uh and in the battlefield of your
users and then you can take decisions uh
and what i can suggest for for for
everyone for every digital business
is is don't underestimate in the power
of data it's better to have the right
data rather than the big data
and i think that once you have a solid
layer of the basic
uh
foundation of your data infrastructure
move to the next one
make it step by step uh there's there
it's there's an it's an endless
journey of what you can seek to find
from your data sometimes by the way
important data pieces can be found
outside of your your
internal data pipeline and like
environmental ones uh
you know but probably this is um
for a later later stage
in a game development journey now if
we're looking at a company whether it's
big or small
one of the things that you know i see
from your experience that you've had
such a wealth of experiences you know
working in bi teams across so many
different companies and organizations
and seeing bi processes
handled both i guess well and and i'm
sure not so well
if i were to now come into a company and
start a bi initiative or create a new
startup and think through bi from the
get-go what you know obviously you know
there's the common tools to use and
there there's the best practices
but from somebody who's gone through you
know not just creating the bi but
actually coming up with the with the
insights from it which is what you
actually want in the end what what are
so what is perhaps the most important
thing to keep in mind as i'm building my
bi infrastructure and my company
that the bi team
could serve the business and not vice
versa uh it's a mistake that i've that i
i made somewhere in the beginning of my
journey i was very ambitious
to build something on where i joined the
startup and we tried to to build
something and
we could have worked on a very simple
you know standard way and you know
making sure that the bus the data unit
supporting the business
and very early in the process we decided
to build a rocket ship
and i think it was wrong i think when
you're starting i need a business
intelligence initiative something on top
of your business intelligence layer
there is the business analyst team and i
think that the biggest thing
you should consider when you're starting
is asking the business holders what is
important for them what do they need
when do they need it what is the
granulation of the the data that will
help them to take better decisions and
from this point start to start
structuring your your data layer and
your data infrastructure otherwise it's
just an end in loop within we sometimes
you can find
very ambitious data people
but they're not focusing on what's
making the money for the company at the
end and you know this is the biggest
thing for the company you need to grow
your customer base you need to make more
revenues that's that's the
the growth drivers and that you know the
data team should support this
and once you're understanding this you
are very focusing on your decision
the big that you know what what which
technology you should use what's the the
size of the data which are the you know
which
data engineers or business analysts you
need to recruit everything is coming
from this route
i love it were you always so fascinated
about data also before
also before your military service as a
kid is you know an analysis and
analyzing data is this always where your
passion lied
no actually no i think that
as a teenager everything related to
mathematics and studying was way way off
my uh
was my horizon
uh
even in my military service it was not
focusing on the computers i i
was more focusing on uh walking
somewhere
um but you know it came to me later in
the journey somewhere i'm writing like a
fourth year and
as a student started working as on the
incredible i found that there is a lot
of information that you can find
a lot of insight you can actually help
the business and then it catch me and
from this point you know the rest of
history
i love it and
if you look today at really the core of
your inspiration
you know you wake up you're running
simple you've been in the bi space for a
long time where do you where do you
gather your inspiration to continue the
way that you're continuing
i just have to win it
it's something that i can't i can't
explain i don't know
there's nothing like i said it's not
like i'm looking on someone
and like steve jobs or
no it's not from there there is
something inside of me
you know that i i'm coming in the
morning and saying no i haven't sold
that yet
it has to be sold i have i have a goal i
have a mission currently in my life
uh and and i need to nail that
and it's something that
probably every entrepreneur is is facing
this
this feeling and it's something that you
cannot explain but once you're feeling
this
you say yeah
it's this one it has i have to win it
and nothing will stop me to this point
and that's that's what drives me you
know
this journey is so volatile but at the
end
moonshot that's our goal what are a few
words that you would use to describe
yourself
uh i'm very stubborn
sometimes
maybe too much
um
but i'm very passionate for what i'm
doing
um
and i think it's a key for for holding
this you know being an entrepreneur and
a
family man and living this especially
during the past uh 18 months with uh
kobe which facing us with uh
all kind of challenges
yeah at the end resilience is everything
and if you're believing in what you're
doing uh and you're keeping surrounding
yourself with with the right people
we'll nail it
and i will make a guy
thank you very very much for the time
and for the insights i loved it
and i wish you guys a simple and thank
you for everything thank you stay safe
and healthy
[Music]